[Musique]
nous sommes à mulhouse ville au passé
industriel dont témoignent encore
aujourd'hui de nombreuses friches ici
d'anciens jardins ouvriers au bord de
l'ill à l'abandon depuis des années ces
derniers vont connaître une véritable
renaissance
à l'instar de nombreux autres sites
emblématiques d'une agglomération qui se
transforme en profondeur de la même
façon que le kilomètre zéro est en passe
de devenir la locomotive à idées du
mulhouse 2.0 nos jardins vont retrouver
leur vocation d' espace nature ouvert au
mulhousien faire de la ville une zone
parsemée des espaces verts et bleus
c'est l'objectif du projet luzia gones à
mulhouse diagonale c'est le projet
urbain majeur pour la ville de mulhouse
sur les dix années à venir c'est
vraiment pour faire changer la vision
des habitants sur leur ville par rapport
à lure sachant que l'eau est très
présente dans mulhouse mais qu'on ne la
voit plus aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
valoriser des sites qui ont vraiment
besoin d'être re montrer aux habitants
l'eau a de tout temps été très présente
dans la ville parcourue par de
nombreuses rivières c'est le
développement industriel de la cité qui
a mené à la couverture de nombre d'entre
elles
les temps changent aujourd'hui
l'impératif n'est plus dégager des
espaces pour installé rue des usines
mais bien de faire sortir longue des
entrailles de la ville pour le plus
grand plaisir des habitants
un projet au long cours le projet il est
sur dix ans au moins aujourd'hui on le
fait partir pour dix ans il ya sept
sites qui sont concernés sur toute la
ville de mulhouse
mais il y en a trois plus
particulièrement qui vont être vraiment
en modifications dans les deux années à
venir
alors ici on est sous le site ce qu'on
appelle plus pas donc les anciens sites
de propreté de la ville
ensuite il va y avoir sur dmc le
réaménagement du steinby schlein qui va
être aussi très visible dans les deux
années à venir et les jardins familiaux
à la sortie sur le canal de la
confluence de la doller en ligne de mire
du projet diagonale créer des espaces de
convivialité de rencontres au fil des
flots sur les différents sites du projet
les verts vont être aménagés en espaces
ouverts
des parcs que les mulhousiens pourront
s'approprier pour se balader se détendre
ou encore trouver un peu de fraîcheur
sur le site de l'appui pas on va
aménager une plage de galets on va faire
des terrasses on va faire un grand parc
c'est vraiment donner une nouveau une
ville nature une ville verte et bleue
c'est vraiment là le fondement c'est ça
c'est la ville nature le bien-être que
les habitants puissent se retrouver des
nouveaux lieux pour venir se promener en
famille en redécouvrir des plages des
jardins on a avec eux lancé un budget
participatif sur le sujet puisque ils
ont pu voter pour avec nous choisir des
endroits où ils voudraient qu'on
installe des gadgets des aménagements
pour les enfants il ya vraiment une
envie de avec nous lancer ce projet
mulhouse ya gonal le site internet
mulhouse c'est vous a ainsi recueilli de
nombreuses propositions des habitants
une consultation a ensuite été lancé
pour départager les différents projets
un bel exemple de démocratie
participative
ça s'est passé en deux temps d'abord on
a recueilli auprès des mulhousiens leur
idée de toutes sortes
il ya plus de 80 idées qui ont été
proposées et ensuite on a mis au vote 27
projets que ce soit sous forme
électronique par le biais de l'âge du
site de l' agence des participations ou
par le parrain bon vieux vote
traditionnel et on a choisi on a les
mulhousiens ont choisi 13 projets ils
ont été près 3000 asexué à s'exprimer et
à voter et sur ses treize projets des
choses extrêmement diverses comme la
signalétique l'installation de hamacs le
fait de pouvoir mettre une guinguette
c'est là ça va permettre aux mulhousiens
de s'approprier cet endroit est de
réaliser pour un budget participatif qui
est de 300000 euros
un certain nombre d'aménagements au bord
de ses berges c'est se réapproprier des
aménagements des bords de rivières de la
nature être vraiment dans le vert et
bleu dans mulhouse vraiment des endroits
magiques qu'on va sublimer avec ce
projet
dans le secteur des anciens ateliers de
la plupart les travaux de démolition ont
déjà commencer d'ici peu ses bâtiments
et cet espace en friche devrait laisser
place à un parc descendant en pente
douce vers l'île d'ici fin 2018 on
devrait commencer à aménager cette
fameuse grande plage et cetera ça ça va
être rapidement visibles et sur dmc
aussi au niveau du steinby schlein d'ici
l'année prochaine on devrait revoir la
présence de ce cours d'eau sur le site
avec des réouverture prévue pour la
ville de coût de l'opération est
budgétée à hauteur de 10 millions
d'euros sur les dix prochaines années
mais seule la commune ne pourrait pas
porter un projet aussi ambitieux ainsi
différents partenaires fournissent un
appui technique autant que financier aux
travaux bien sûr ce l'initiateur c'est
la ville de mulhouse 1 puisque c'est
la ville de mulhouse qui a lancé ce
grand projet mulhouse diagonale mais
avec nous des partenaires vraiment
importants que sont les syndicats de
rivières le syndicat mixte de la doller
et le syndicat de delisle et l' agence
de l'eau qui sont avec nous de grands
partenaires sur ce projet l'agencé de
l'eau et le conseil départemental du
haut-rhin apporteront un important
soutien financier au projet ainsi ces
deux partenaires qui nous seront 30 % du
coût des travaux solide de lancer plus
bas du secteur dmc et déjà la famille